Now we really found the inverse function here. But notice that it's labeled as
y. And that could get confusing since I already had a y up here. Which stood
for my original function. Y was the output of this function. So in order to not
confuse these two. Let's label this f inverse of x. So instead of having y
equals the quantity x minus 3 divided by 2. We'll have f inverse of x equals x
minus 3 divided by 2. Now, notice that this is actually a line too. If we
divide 2 into each term, we'll have f inverse of x equals 1 half x minus 3
halves. negative 3 halves or negative 1 and a half is our y intercept. And
slope hear would be positive 1 half. And I just want to caution you to be
careful with this negative 1. This isn't an exponent like we normally think
about it. This is just the notation for the inverse of a function. So if we
take sum input x and we multiply it by 2 and add 3. To undo these operations we
would have to subtract 3 first and then divide by 2. Now, that should make
sense since we're just undoing the last operation we did to x and working
backwards. So we need to undo add by 3, which is minus 3, and then we undo the
multiplication of 2, which is divide by 2. Let's look closely at the graph of
this function. And its inverse to see one more unique relationship. It's
actually one we've already encountered. Here on this blue graph, I've graphed a
line, y equals 2 x plus 3. We have a y intercept at 3. And a slope of up two
units, right one unit to get our next point of 1, 5. Now, our inverse function
was 1 half x minus 3 halves. Or we could have written the equation like this. X
minus 3 all divided by 2. It's the same exact line. Notice that for this line,
our y-intercept is at negative 3 halves, and the slope is positive 1, right 2.
Positive 1, right 2. So again, this was our original function and then this on
was the inverse. Now what I want to show you is this line y equals x. Here's
the black line drawn in. Notice that the function and its inverse are reflected
over the line y equals x. In other words if we fold this part over the black
line, we would get this inverse function of our graph. And if we fold this part
of the original function over our black line we get this part of the inverse
function. If we look more closely at a point like 0.3, which is on our original
function, we can find a corresponding point on the inverse function. This one's
3.0. Notice the x and the y coordinates have changed.They switched places. This
is what's so unique about inverse functions. The x and y-coordinates always
change. So if we choose another point in the graph, like negative 1.5, 0 for
our function, we can find it on our inverse function. That would be 0, negative
1.5. And again, the x and the y-coordinate switch places. Even for a point like
negative 4, comma negative 5, we can find that on our inverse. On our inverse
function it will be negative 5, negative 4. That point is right here.